ich komme mir so dumm fall luca allem
ein name ist herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einem neuen video von job
dasteht nicht locker da steht das
hebräisch und ich sitze hier nicht
alleine werde jetzt waldbesitzer will
ich sie nicht einmal der damen und
herren ihr seht schon revier kostenlos
ihr seht ihr wie nicht mehr stop
abnehmtipps nur 15 euro für ein tennis
ist meine damen und herren wir haben uns
die nicht aus irgendeinem grund
versammelt sondern aus irgendeinem grund
richten sich zwar machen wollte
zusammenhang eco test denn wir sind ja
ja das war ja so ja in der tat das
funktioniert so die ju zuerst ich hätte
ich gehe raus dann geht mir jetzt mal
raus und dann gehe ich wieder rein und
dann gehst du jetzt raus das genau
wir fangen direkt an mit der ersten
frage meine damen und herren um nicht
korrekt bestimmen zu können wie alt bist
du uns über 50 okay jetzt bin ich dran
und ich bin mal gespannt was sie
zukommen wenn wir die kuh das bestimmen
zu können die als beste ja da geht schon
los
es geht schon los mit den fragen leute
loca loca loca löse folgende analogie
junge gegen schriftlich man gleich
mädchen schrägstrich frau hitomi ist
denn das revier auslöse folgende
analogie junge mann mädchen frau oder
wenn man das ist das nicht also trick
die frage was da schon wieder besser
nächste frage ist jetzt schon wieder so
ein komischer analogie einfach man hat
sogar noch verbleibende zeit pro frage
ok medaille tapferkeit lohnen geld
medaille tapferkeit und lohn gleich auf
jede medaille habe ich für tapferkeit
bekommen lohn erhalte ich für
arbeitslose folgende analogie augen
sehen wasser trinken ja also was machen
die augen zu sehen und was macht das
wasser es ist flüssig trinken macht
keinen sinn drei solchen späte augen
sehen und wasser ist nachts möchte von
allen guten geistern verlassen ich muss
man die ganze zeit nach analogien lösen
also morgen heute samstagmorgen heute
samstag zurück das heißt freitagmorgen
heute samstag findet die beiden
identischen bilder 12 auf keinen fall 13
ist es auch nicht es ist eins und vier
hätte ich diese kacke lohnfrage wenn da
nicht eine rein gekommen wäre natürlich
die safe beantworten können findet die
identischen bilder okay leute da bin ich
extrem schlecht dran weil ich hier bin
gibt das müsste das hier sein
das ist auch falsch 2000 jahre später
gibt es nicht sich leicht gibt es kein
gleiches oder welche teile müssen
kombiniert werden um diese hilfe zu
erhalten
auf jeden fall ist die linke hälfte der
hier und die rechner hälfte müsste
eigentlich theoretisch
seitdem ist kombiniert werden um diesen
wert zu erhalten
okay wir haben hier arbeiten in der ecke
wie eine orangene style und dann gäbe es
dann eben euro und ich bin sicher wenn
man keine ahnung 83 weise hier bis wir
wieder schauen welche teile kombiniert
werden müssen bei frage nummer 9 also
wir müssen das hier in der mitte
erhalten 1 und 2 sind es definitiv nicht
1 und 6 sind es sind 16 auch man
geometrie ich hasse sowas als das ist
hier noch mal die tiere dann ist auch
diesmal die fünf wird dabei eins hast
könnte 1 und 2002 ist sie welche dieser
figuren sind technisch korrekt also wir
müssen jetzt gucken welcher was hier von
tatsächlich technisch im neuen jahr auf
keinen fall eines ist auf jeden fall
korrekt zwei und drei ist nicht korrekt
wie es korrekt also 14 15
gibt's nicht so auswahlmöglichkeit 1 45
18 steht hier aber auch also nehme ich
das hier ist ja auch wieder richtig
freute ich eigentlich das ist ja hat er
nicht mit einem iq test zu tun bei der
meinung nach sondern einfach nur das gt
r von uns darum schnellstmöglich gegen
eine dumme antwort aus die man heraus zu
pressen das ist ja also das ist ja das
ist enttäuschend
auch gehören jetzt auch keinen sonst
auch keinen sinn und ist das ist es das
ist 114
das habe ich jetzt nicht hier muss man
schauen was die beiden identischen
bilder sind also heinz und zehn ist
nicht korrekt weil da zwei schornsteine
sind zwei und acht auch nicht weil ihr
die tür fehlt 3 und 7 auch nicht wegen
den schornsteinen dann haben wir wieder
sechs und neun haben wir diesmal 6 und
neu sind korrekt ja sechs und neun
es ist so schwer oder er wird um warum
was mache ich falsch
was mache ich falsch die 2d ist falsch
wie viele ziegelsteine braucht man um
die mauer zu [ __ ] er 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 oder
22 wegen dem hier noch ich habe keine
ahnung freunde
ich würde sagen ich nehme jetzt einmal
hier kommt das schießen einfach ist hier
komplett dem 33 22 muss es dann doch
muss den com 20 setzte die zahlenreihe
vor 2 4 6 8 10 12 14
wieso ist das frage 13 16 14 16 18 ein
geschwür das geht nicht auf das ist viel
zu einfach warum habe ich dann für alle
anderen hat minuten zeit das ist viel zu
einfach dafür schon wieder eine
zahlenreihe 2+2 sind denn je 2 mal 2
sind 44 04 sind 16 16 mal 16 und hat 256
2 16
weil das 56
das können
20 eigentlich haben wir ja keinen sinn
doch stimmt ja hab ich hab ich dir den
bernern deinen kopf schon jetzt als
fünfzehnter frage wieder mal eine
zahlenreihe 2 +3 sind 55 plus 4 sind 94
plus 15 14 14 bis 26 20 prosieben sind
27 ich stehe gerade sorgen schlauch mal
was geht ab alter +3 ich komme mir so
dumm fall luca 5 6 727 natürlich als
sechzehnter frage auch wieder eine
zahlenreihe drei plus eins sind 44 +4
sind 8 + 3 mal 4 + 5 ist eine ewigkeit
später kein plan
ich habe absolut keinen plan ich sage
einfach mal 164 weil ich das hier schon
so an lächelt auch so ach so okay okay
okay dann
81 alle männer sind ärzte alle ärzte
sind verheiratet welches
schlussfolgerung stimmt alle männer sind
verheiratet einigen ärzten sind
verheiratet einige ärzte sind frauen
keine schlussfolgerung stimmt also wenn
alle männer ärzte sind und alle erste
verheiratet sind dann sind einige ärzte
hätte das macht überhaupt keinen sinn
alle männer tanzen und sich schon mal
klar ist alle ärzte sind vor allem als
das heißt einige ärztin verheiratet das
ist richtig weil meine katzen sind
frauen könnte auch sagen könne alle
hunde sind lebewesen alles kleine des
bösartig welche schlussfolgerungen
stimmt alle bösartigen hunderte kleine
lebewesen einige kleine hunde sind keine
bösartige wesen einige böse grunde so
kleine wir sind alle nicht bösartigen
runde sind lebewesen die nicht klein bei
etwas das macht gar keinen sinn alle
bürger an den bundes kleine lebewesen
also bundes und lebewesen ist klar
einige kleine runde ist und keine mühe
st einige hundert einige kleine
lebewesen
da steht ja überhaupt nicht da bist du
eine frau bist fragen
ich weiß ich muss der mann oder eine
frau ich bin frau das ist jetzt hier
meine auswertungen haben hier steht da
die kurs 123 ist überdurchschnittlich
intelligent die antworten hatte ich alle
richtig geld da war arbeit richtig war
mal was hier nochmal das richtig war
hierbei umfasst 82 dachte 1 müsste mit
das hätte auch nicht gestimmt hier sind
auch wieder so ein paar sachen nicht
richtig hier ist alles richtig da hab
ich ja irgendwas angekreuzt habe ich
irgendwas angekreuzt also meine kuh ist
auf jeden fall 123 jetzt schauen wir mal
zusammen was der regierte ja ich bin ja
ich habe bei den geometrischen formen
kurzarbeitet so viel ist dann gar nicht
falsch schau mal hier würden wir aber
normalen thissen machen luca der von den
handschellen psychologen hätte
durchgeführt werden sollen ja auch nicht
vom internet von beiden basispunkte
würde sich sicherlich ergeben dass ich
der intelligent ja das war ein bisschen
wie die leute das was jetzt hier vom
video das war es jetzt hier vom video
hier können jetzt hier mal den kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten mal einen
schub aus schenkungen jetzt findet ihr
zwei andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnenten zeit könnt ihr auch die
glocke klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen